-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with John Oliver.
I always think about you --
You've been very critical,
rightfully so,
of FIFA over the years.
-Yes, because it's basically
a criminal cartel
that stages a tournament
every four years.
-Yeah, there's a perfect example
of what I was just doing.
[ Laughter ]
But, you know, a lot of people,
they basically just stepped up
and did as right a thing
as they are likely to do.
-It is kind of amazing.
If you have lost the moral high
ground, as a country, to FIFA...
[ Laughter ]
...you are morally subterranean
because they will try
every possible angle to do
the wrong thing, and if they
couldn't find that
and they ended up kicking them
out, things are bad.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And they did try to do the wrong
version of the right thing.
-That's the best move, saying,
"Yeah, you can compete,
but just not as Russia.
You got to change your names
and you got to wear
fake mustaches."
[ Laughter ]
"That'll teach you, right?
That'll teach you."
-But it's not change your name
to like
the Grasshoppers,
which would be fun.
It's always like "the Federation
of Russian Athletes."
-That's right. That's right.
Exactly.
"The team formerly known as
the Russian football team."
But also you just cannot let
FIFA occupy any kind of morality
here because they are banning
Russia from the World Cup
in Qatar...
[ Laughter ]
...which is basically
built on blood.
So yeah, FIFA,
in the macro sense,
are still continuing to do
the wrong thing
and will until the end
of their existence.
-And yet -- I know this because
we text a lot during
international football --
I'm going to say "football"
because you're here.
-I appreciate that.
-No worries.
I want you to feel comfortable.
I don't want you to be like,
"What?"
[ Laughter ]
-You're a great host, Seth.
-How invested will you be
in the World Cup?
-You know, it just gets to
the fundamental flaw
of you as a human being.
I mean me, but also you.
-Yes, also me, yeah.
-Because you cannot
defend the fact
the World Cup is happening
in Qatar.
And I am going to watch it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I am going to criticize it
before and after.
-Yeah.
-And who knows? During.
-But I am going to watch it.
And what does that make me?
It's some version of
a kind of lower-H hypocrite.
[ Laughter ]
-It is lower H.
-Yeah, lower H, lower H.
It's not capital H.
-No, I would never say that
of you.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there's the thing.
I love the product
they make so much,
just like drug cartels
make a very fine cocaine.
[ Laughter ]
-That's very nice of you to say.
Nobody ever says that about
the drug cartels.
Let's not forget that they're
making very good cocaine.
-I cannot say this enough, and
this isn't sponsored content,
the Sinaloa Cartel...
[ Laughter ]
...makes some of,
if not the best, cocaine around.
[ Laughter ]
If you're not taking
Sinaloa Cocaine --
-I will say, this is starting to
sound like an ad,
but I'm gonna let you finish.
[ Laughter ]
It does feel like this is very,
like, written marketing speak.
-I think that is the secret of
lots of late-night shows.
People do often come on
with something to sell.
For me, unfortunately, it is the
fact that the Sinaloa Cartel --
[ Laughter ]
Even as I'm doing this bit,
I'm realizing there are
other cartels
who might not find this
quite as funny.
[ Laughter ]
And that's the prob-- I get too
[bleep] relaxed on this show,
and I either imply that the
coronavirus is not going to be
a big deal in New York, or I
start saying, for some reason,
that the Sinaloa Cartel --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What I like to picture right
now, as this airs, is
there's a rival cartel,
and they're having whatever
kind of meeting they have,
and there's, like,
two cheetahs and whatnot.
They're having the meeting.
And there's a TV on in the
corner, and this is on,
and then all of a sudden,
the head of the cartel --
-That's right. And before
this moment's gone on,
they've been talking about,
"Do you think Wally's getting
a little bit too much
screen time?"
[ Laughter ]
-And the head of the cartel's
like, "No."
He respects Wally.
-That's right.
-He respects what he's doing.
He wants power.
-He's going to do anything
it takes to get it.
-But right now they're saying,
"Turn it up,"
because it's on
in the background.
And now they're going --
-"Hang on, shh, shh. Wait.
The Sinaloa?"
[ Laughter ]
-This is very -- We've really
stepped in it, I feel like.
[ Laughter ]
We'll get out of it.
-It'll be fine.
-What's the worst
that can happen?
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-And that's the gif that people
will use in the future,
when someone gets a little bit
too comfortable about
something and it blows up
in their face.
"What's the worst
that could happen?"
[ Laughter ]
-This is good, though,
because I feel like
this is erasing our interview
from two years ago.
Like now, this is
more interesting.
-You got to keep it fresh.
-Nobody's going to look back.
They're gonna be like,
"They stepped in it freshly."
You actually went,
right after Crimea,
you went to interview Snowden.
-I did.
-Which I imagine was tense
in its own right,
but even more so
because of the annexation.
-It was, actually, and to
the extent that, we got there --
we hadn't told anyone,
our fixer or our crew,
who we were there to interview
because we were keeping it
all very -- See, we hadn't told
HBO either.
So we were keeping it all
very, very --
-What did HBO think
you were doing?
-They didn't -- They thought --
I think they thought I was in
New York preparing for the show.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Whereas, surprise.
[ Laughter ]
I'm in Russia.
So yeah, we got there,
and it was very, very tense,
and we were clearly,
very obviously being watched.
The Russians were not -- There
was no subterfuge going on.
They were very obviously
following us.
And our fixer was
really, really worried.
And then when we eventually
said, just before we were
going to do the interview,
"Actually, it's Snowden,"
it was immediate relaxation
in the room and from the fixer.
"Oh, that's okay. That's fine.
You can talk about that.
I thought you were just going to
talk about the other thing."
And then he wouldn't even say
the word.
-He wouldn't even say "Crimea"?
-He wouldn't even say "Crimea"
because I think he knew that we
were being listened to.
So he just said, "If you're not
talking about the other thing,
this will be okay."
And everything calmed down.
But it was very, very tense.
-I would imagine.
And then, 2017, you did a piece
about Putin.
-Yes.
-I'm assuming -- Do you reach
out, like, for comment?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
We had a list of questions.
"Vladimir, can you just get back
to us on this?
Because if you have a response,
we'd love to build the response
into the body of the script,
if that's okay."
I can't remember if we --
Maybe as a courtesy, we reached
out to the Kremlin.
-They respect that.
-That's right.
I do think he would have some
queries with what we said.
-Yeah.
-No, the only thing we really
did before it went on was really
jack up our cybersecurity.
-Oh, that's very smart.
-Yeah. Have you done that yet?
Because the Sinaloa Cartel
may be --
[ Laughter ]
-Are they good at that?
Do they have a good tech guy?
-Seth, I can't say this enough.
They're good at everything.
-Oh, my God.
This is a #ad.
John Oliver, everybody.
"Last Week Tonight" airs
Sunday nights on HBO
and streams on HBO Max.